polls have opened in crucial midterm
elections in the U.S the vote will
determine if Democrats lose control of
Congress and with it their ability to
push ahead with President Joe Biden's
agenda for the next two years
Republicans seem set to do well in the
boat after focusing on the economy in
the campaign that more than half of
Republican candidates say they believe
the unfounded claim that Donald Trump
won the 2020 election and this is
Raising fears among Democrats that the
very future of democracy could be at
stake in this election
now we'll get more from one of our
correspondents in Washington in just a
moment but first we're going to hear
from DW's William glue Croft
the midterm elections are called that
because they take place in the middle of
the president's four-year term so Joe
Biden was elected in 2020 which means
the midterms are now 2022. they're
always an important indicator of how
voters feel about the party in power and
how they feel about how the United
States is doing who wins the midterms
can make or break the rest of a
president's time in office and Joe Biden
is poised to lose his Democratic
majority at least in the House of
Representatives if not the Senate too
and here's why all 435 seats in the
House are up for reelection a majority
is anything over 218. in the Senate
there are a hundred seats Democrats have
the bare minimum of a majority there
this year only 35 of those seats are
being contested and not every race has
the same impact on the balance of power
that's because the U.S is so politically
divided Republicans and Democrats have a
lock on most of the seats now of course
election day will probably bring
surprises and upsets but analysts think
that only 35 of the 435 House Seats and
just about five of those 35 Senate races
are what we call toss-ups where the
outcome is really unclear now Democrats
have their work cut out for them if they
want to hang on to power why well let's
look at history the party that controls
the White House and that's the Democrats
right now almost always lose seats in
the midterms that's been a stronger
Trend in the house as you can see here
over the decades than the Senate but
both sides of Congress tend to get a
shellacking which is what President
Barack Obama described the massive
losses he suffered in the 2010 midterms
and of course there are a lot of factors
that determine the outcome of the
midterms they're of course major events
and policies of the party in power but
also voter turnout which side can get
more of their people to the polls and
structural advantages this year Republic
Republicans in the house just have a
better chance of flipping seats and have
fewer of their own to defend the
situation in the Senate is a bit more of
a fair fight but still a challenge for
Democrats and then the unknowns how will
newly redrawn voting maps for House
Seats impact the party's chances what
about new voting regulations in some
places due to baseless claims of voter
fraud and of course Donald Trump he
isn't on the ballot but several of his
preferred candidates are and how they
and Republicans more broadly perform
could signal things to come for 2024 and
American democracy Beyond
all right straight to Washington DC now
where we can speak to our correspondent
Stefan Simons Stefan it's a big election
day today the polls have opened but
people have actually been sending in
their votes for a couple of weeks
already haven't they can you tell us how
this could potentially affect the
outcome
yeah hi they have indeed in record
numbers actually and how could this
impact the results and when we get
results that is the really really
interesting question here and why is
that because Florida for example they're
already processing or the right term for
this is canvassing send in votes bail in
votes
um but States like Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin the State lost there forbid
this to happen before Election Day
meaning they start canvassing processing
those mail-in ballots just today they
started about an hour ago to do this and
there are hundreds and thousands of this
what that means is that results from
Florida we will may have tonight later
today or early tomorrow morning
Pennsylvania Wisconsin and a few other
states where they just start to count
those votes
um well that could take days until we
have really an accurate picture of who
won what race for a gubernatorial races
Governor or senate or congress all right
so it might take a couple of days let's
take a look at the both the houses of
Congress which are currently controlled
by the Democrats but Republicans really
only need a few extra seats to take
control don't they so tell us how easy
it will be for them to do that
well in the house is pretty much a done
deal they need to pick up five seats to
really uh kick the Democrats out of the
majority in the House of Representatives
that should be absolutely possible for
the Republicans they are absolutely
hopeful and positive and excited about
that perspective of course send it a
little bit of a different thing now
it is just taking one one
seat in the senate for the Republicans
to negate the majority the Democrats
right now have and that's only because
of the deciding vote of Vice President
Kamala Harris
but it is really not that easy for
Republicans at least it is not
considered that easy to really topple
this or move a majority in the Senate
house yes everybody expects a a
significant loss for the Democrats in
the Senate maybe maybe and the Democrats
are very hopeful they can hold on for
the Senate why is this important because
real laws will be decided before they go
to the president for the
for his signature and to become lost
they have to go to the Senate it's not
that the House of Representatives can
make a decision create a law and then it
goes to the Senate and their rubber
stamp is if you have the majority in one
in the house but not in the Senate it's
getting really difficult all right
Stefan Simon's in Washington D.C thanks
so much for that
now the world is watching the U.S
midterms as the outcome could of course
change U.S foreign policy now while
issues like the economy have been
dominating the campaign the war in
Ukraine is also costing U.S consumers in
many ways and some are now questioning
how much longer the U.S should support
Ukraine's fight against Russia
Russia's war against Ukraine is one the
U.S has not been able to look away from
Americans have already sent more than 60
billion dollars worth of assistance into
this war zone Democrat President Joe
Biden has promised to continue to do all
it takes to defend Ukraine sovereignty
As Americans head to the polls and these
midterm elections U.S Congress is
expected to turn more Republican and the
big question everybody is asking is what
impact that will have on U.S assistance
to Ukraine and other allies well the
answer depends on who you ask there will
be enough support no matter who controls
which house and given President Biden
still in the white house so I I am quite
confident that very very strong support
will continue for Ukraine yet one
prominent Republican started sending a
very different signal ahead of the
elections Kevin McCarthy is the top
Republican in the House of
Representatives he says he believes
Americans would no longer be willing to
write a blank check to Ukraine in the
face of a biting recession back home
after all the soaring prices of gas food
and housing topped the list of worries
for ordinary Americans Democrats fear
that a republican majority in Congress
could soon make Ukraine a domestic
bargaining chip but Paul so more than
two-thirds of Americans back U.S
assistance to Ukraine even if there is a
republican majority in the house and or
the Senate
I think perhaps the experience of
working together so closely
and so confidentially and with so much
trust on sanctions might perhaps help to
defuse
um
tensions over trade protectionism in
general
or over the larger question of how to
deal with malignant Chinese behavior in
the trade and Technology Realm
I'm going to say I'm cautiously
optimistic on that
warnings that China may try to invade
Taiwan rather sooner than later could
become the next test for the west and
for America's willingness to pay a price
for Global Leadership
is that China may try to invade Taiwan
rather sooner than later could become
the next test for the west and for
America's willingness to pay a price for
Global Leadership
and we can discuss this further with
David wilp she's a director of the
Berlin office of the German Marshall
fund that's a nonpartisan public policy
Think Tank thanks for being with us suda
let's start with a question being asked
by many people here in Europe right now
do you think that America's position
regarding Russia's war in Ukraine will
change if Republicans win control of one
or both houses of Congress
so Terry I'll give you a nuanced answer
um to your question I think there's
overwhelming bipartisan support for
Ukraine in Washington at the moment and
in fact the friction is actually between
the White House and Congress uh behind
closed doors many many members of
Congress Republicans and Democrats but
mostly Republicans are actually asking
President Biden to do more what will
change of course and this actually
aligns with growing Republican voter
sentiment is that
um the U.S doesn't want to just do it
alone I think Republicans if they take
the majority in the house and even in
the Senate they will be more scrutiny as
Kevin McCarthy who's poised to perhaps
be the next Speaker of the House said
there won't be any blank checks for
Ukraine but they're going to expect
European Partners to step up support for
Ukraine Senator Tom Cotton already said
from our Arkansas Republican that of
course the U.S has to support Ukraine
because it has the sophisticated
military
um weapons that Ukraine needs but um he
wants Europe to do more
okay
um the midterms of course are being
closely watched around the world not
least in Moscow and Beijing do these
elections have the potential to shape
U.S foreign policy towards Russia and
China
um most certainly I think that
um you know I think if the Republicans
take the house which is usually normal
in a midterm election that the Congress
switches to a different party than the
party that's in the white house then of
course it'll be a raucous two years of
Investigations into Hunter Biden the
Afghanistan withdrawal and perhaps even
articles of impeachment and countries
like Russia and China that are using
disinformation to sow Discord within the
United States will certainly use this as
an opportunity to divide Americans even
more in a very Polo polarized atmosphere
in the run-up to 2024 and the world is
watching um the state of democracy in
the United States right now
so the state of democracy is at stake as
it were what about EU U.S relations will
transatlantic relations and this is your
bread and butter well transatlantic
relations be affected if for example the
House and Senate flip and Biden becomes
a lame duck
um as I mentioned
overwhelming the partisan support for
Ukraine and also also for NATO NATO NATO
is very popular Institution for
Democrats and Republicans alike and I
think there was incredible cohesion
between the United States and Europe
with Russia's war against Ukraine and I
I don't see that faltering immediately
but there is of course friction on the
horizon specifically with you know
Germany and Europe's relations with
China there's also growing Hardline
um uh you know
cooperation between Democrats and
Republicans on the U.S stance toward
China and
um also that the Europeans also need to
do more in their own backyard and that
military spending is necessary so I
think that there's frictions there and
also with Biden's inflation reduction
act there have also been of course
disadvantages for Europe because uh by
this policy of promoting the middle
class is going to hurt European
companies involved in the electric
vehicle industry
so to thank you very much that was
suited David wilp director of the Berlin
office of the German Marshall fund
good to see you